okay today we have a puzzle so I'm gonna
give you all the numbers from 1 to 15 I
suspect you're gonna shorten this
dramatically in the edit your challenge
is can you take numbers from 1 to 15 and
can you rearrange them into a new water
such that any two adjacent numbers add
to give you a square number so for
example you could put 1 let's give it a
go we go to try we can put one there and
then next to it we could put 3 you go
okay that's pretty good because 1 for 3
is 4 that's a square number I could
check 6 here because 3 plus 6 is 9
that's a square number Oh what am I
gonna do what can I add to that to make
it a square number 10 no what right and
then so on so we'll give you a second if
you want to try it so we have to use all
of them yeah fuse all of them in one
long line any order you want that any
two that are adjacent have to add to a
square number
welcome back thank you for trying the
puzzle if you got it could be it could
be days later my goodness how you have
aged but you know you gave it a go you
saying buddy you didn't think it was
possible like it feels unlikely you know
but it can be done and I gave you a
false start it doesn't work if you have
these numbers in this order so I
deliberately and very meanly gave you a
starting point that does not work why
would you do this because I'm a jerk I
want people to work it out for
themselves but why doesn't it work right
because this does that this fulfills the
requirement every two of these do add to
give you a square number but then you
just you can't join up the rest of them
right you've run out of another room so
the way I went about solving this when I
first did it was I thought okay I'm
gonna draw all the possible links
because you start looking at this and
you're like okay where 10 works with 15
cuz I get 25 but 10 also works with 6
and so actually I've got other options
for how I put them in the same order and
some of them have more possible links or
neighbors they could go with then you
can actually put in a long line so I was
like right right I'm gonna do this
there's why but one over here I can do
them in order that's one okay 2 1 & 2
don't add to give you a square number so
I'm gonna put 2 over there out of the
way right ok 3 nothing I can add link to
1 because that gives me 4 that is a
square number now four doesn't work with
anything so far but does work with five
so five over there six works with three
and so you can see if I only had the
numbers from 1 to 6 it wouldn't be
possible to order them so every single
pair adds to a square number put 7 into
the mix 7 goes with 2 because it gives
you 9 8 adds on to 1 gives you 9 9 fits
in off 7 because I get 16 10 links into
6 16 11 and still now I've got these
series I could use in fact if this looks
familiar that there is the original
series I gave 8 1 3 6 10
is one possible ordering but there's no
way so far to link it up with the rest
of them we'll keep filling these in 12
to 4:13 we'll also link to 12 because I
can get 25 but I can also get 16 so that
links to AHA okay so now we're starting
to join this all together let's put in
14 and 14 is the first number where now
everything holds together because 14 25
and 16 we've now got a connected network
or graph whatever you want to call it
but there's no path right so this would
work but you've missed one and eight
that would work but you've missed these
so at 14 it's all joined together but
doesn't work 15 is the one you need to
hold it all together because 15 fills in
this gap 1 there's 25 and 16 and now
there's our solution 8 1 15 10 6 3 13 12
and then all the way along that tail and
so that is the order you've got to put
those numbers so that every single pair
between them adds to a square number and
I annoyingly I picked this bit here of
this curve knowing that that is not a
valid part of the path that goes all the
way through this square sums Network
that makes 15 that makes 15 a prisoner's
remember it's the first number for which
you can order the numbers so every
single so you you a right braiser thing
that doesn't feel likely and it's
because I pick 15 because up until then
doesn't work I could pick 16 actually
because 16 you can add on to 9 to get 25
okay
oh wait all 17 okay so 17 goes over
there and so now you think well there
you go
and there's a path 16 all the way
through to 17 you have a perfectly valid
solution but why stop there why not do
it from 1 to 18 18 fits in over here if
there's 18 oh now now we've got a
problem because if you put 18 over there
there's no longer a way to go through
the whole network going through every
single number once and once only because
we've got a tail here sticking off and
we've got a little tail sticking here
and if we start here and go that way we
can never get back to 18
we start here we can never go back for
these guys so we've broken it so it
works for all the numbers from 15 to 17
and then 18 breaks it but what if it
works again after that
so we'd call this a graph in mathematics
and graph theory is what we're kind of
using to solve this puzzle and we're
looking for a path a path there's any
kind of journey which doesn't go through
the same vertex more than once and if we
have a path that goes through every
single vertex then it's called a
Hamiltonian path and so to solve this
puzzle you're looking for the
Hamiltonian path which goes all the way
through the graph so let's try adding on
a few more numbers and see if we can get
to work for a bigger value if I add 19
over here that doesn't solve our two
tails problem over there so as long as
this exists there are no solutions 20
doesn't help Oh actually let's now
solved one tail problem so we can come
in here oh babe if we come in here we
either go around that way or we go
around that way because we had it have
to come off and do the rest of this and
because of this bottleneck here and here
you do one way if you loop around then
you can't get out so that's still not
solvable we need another way out of this
loop before we can do it
21 oh done to get router 21 can go down
here because it links 15 which I'm gonna
run under there too for so these are
crossing but that's that's not a new
vertex right obviously I'm just drawing
the links 22 links up 3-2 14 does that
get us out of our problem because we can
come through here and out but then we
can't get ours - it's still not doable
it can be done once we get to 23 so if
we put 23 in let's pop it down there now
it is possible to trace all the way
through this network show shall we give
it a go I have spoken too soon okay we
can work this out so okay see if we can
do this you go start from 18 because
that's like a little tail over here if
we come in here and we all the way
around here
I suspect we need to mop up these
because if we leave any of these behind
we're gonna be
troubles that's come down take those get
into here come up here oh yeah here we
go then we go across 21 15 10 6 1917 8 1
and there you go so it's possible to
find a Hamiltonian path on the graph as
soon as we add node 23 but very sadly
when we add node 24 it breaks again so
24 joins 1 to 12 24 goes there and then
one thinks to 12th and now it's broken
again but when you add 25 its fixed
again and it then works for 26 it works
with 27 and it works all the way up so
we think as far as we're aware from 25
onwards it works for every possible
value you can somehow find a path
through this network well it's not over
yet people if you'd like to see even
bigger graphs with more nodes and their
Hamiltonian paths have a look at our
extra footage over on numberphile 2
you'll also hear more stories from Matt
including how he made bit of a park a
square of this issue when he was doing
his book and you'll hear from a very
special guest I'll put links down in the
description and in all the usual places
thanks for watching